i think tom holland
just confirmed
that toby maguire or andrew garfield
is in
spiderman no way home what's going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder i'm warren thompson and we did
not get a spider-man no way home trailer
2 today but if you watch my video i did
a few days ago you would have known that
we knew it wasn't going to be coming out
today as sad as that is but the future
is bright hopefully we get it within the
next couple of weeks however today we
did get some really
really interesting news about spider-man
now we home from entertainment weekly
involving a scene with tom holland
aunt may
john favreau and another superhero and
get this in this description of this
scene they actually have to specify
which version of the character they are
talking about this combined with some
leaks going around and some insider
information i have received leads us to
believe that in this scene it is toby
maguire spider-man that has joined tom
holland marissa tome and jon favreau's
characters in spider-man no way home so
let's dive into it and if you are new we
are giving away an awesome spider-man
variant bring arts figurine all you have
to do to enter to win this is subscribe
to my channel and subscribe to cosmic
culture and comment on the latest videos
this will end at the end of the month so
today we have an article from
empireonline.com
empire magazine they're the ones who
released the exclusive spider-man photos
over the weekend and they will be
running an exclusive article in their
magazine and it comes out this thursday
october 28th but in the meantime they
released an article giving us a little
bit more information about spider-man no
way home to hold us off until thursday
and until we get that trailer but the
article actually is pretty revealing and
i think it's actually a marketing
technique by sony which i will talk
about later on but let's dive into what
this says and i'm just going to go over
it and read it word by word so get this
it starts off by saying throughout his
time in the spider-man suit tom holland
has got to shoot some spectacular stuff
rubbing shoulders with the avengers in
captain america civil wars epic airport
fight spending plenty of time with tony
stark and spider-man homecoming and
playing a significant part in the fight
back against thanos in avengers infinity
war and in-game but
in the upcoming spider-man no way home
the actor tells empire that he filmed
one of the coolest scenes i've ever shot
a sequence including a character he
wasn't at liberty to divulge so right
off the bat when you hear
tom holland can't mention who a
character is in a scene you
automatically think well this has got to
be toby mcguire's character or andrew
garfield's character but they actually
give us more to believe that this is
indeed the case it goes on to say what
he could say is that the scene features
his peter parker and i stress that it
literally says his peter parker marissa
tomei's aunt may and john favreau's
happy hogan along with a mystery fourth
character now it gets even better but
let me just stress how they are having
to specify
which characters these are they
literally say his peter parker and they
have to clarify it's marissa tomei's
aunt may and it's john f rose happy
hogan now i didn't think that there
would be another happy hogan in the film
there might not be but i think there
might be more than one aunt may in the
film which is why they have to specify
here and i think we all know why they
have to specify which peter parker this
is here's what tom holland had to say
about the scene it's four people sitting
at a table having a conversation about
what it's like to be a superhero and it
was amazing the other day we watched the
scene my brother and i and our jaws were
on the floor okay can we really expect
him to be talking about anyone besides
toby or andrew maybe matt murdock but
i'll touch on that in a bit tom holland
literally said they were talking about
what it's like to be a superhero which
means that fourth person has to be a
superhero himself or herself but i truly
believe that it is toby rumor has it
right now that we are actually going to
get the great power great responsibility
line in this scene and i stress that
right now it's just a rumor but
according to this rumor it's going to be
toby maguire spider-man sitting down
with tom holland spider-man aunt may and
happy and toby maguire spider-man is
going to be talking to tom holland and
he's going to say peter with great power
comes great responsibility my uncle ben
told me that if this is truly what we
are going to get i think everybody is
going to lose their minds i know i am
i'll probably cry not gonna lie i've
seen a few people kind of in the
industry online tweeting about this and
i asked a personal source and they said
they heard this but they did not confirm
that that's exactly what's happening so
take it as a rumor for right now but man
do i want this rumor to be true now
here's something that is really really
interesting empire magazine goes along
to say cue all the speculation about who
that fourth chair belongs to could it be
another avenger joining the already
confirmed doctor strange or might it
hint at the long rumored crossover
between holland's peter parker and those
played by andrew garfield and toby
maguire in previous big screen
live-action iterations of spider-man so
even in this article by empire they are
stating could it be andrew garfield or
tobey maguire let me explain how this
works empire can't really say much that
sony doesn't want them to say sony most
likely approved this article before it
went out and they definitely approved
what tom holland said before he said it
and if tom holland said something that
actually couldn't go out to the public
they would make sure that that didn't
happen so to me this is just a marketing
technique by sony and it's kind of
genius i mean they have not addressed
the other two spider-man yet but they
keep letting other people hint at it
they let empire magazine hint at it they
let andrew garfield and jimmy fallon
hint at it they tweet three spider
emojis when talking about spiderman no
way home and they just let people like
me and all of us create the hype for the
movie it's kind of genius it's
frustrating as heck but it's kind of
genius because think about it who could
this really be it could be matt murdock
but from what i've been told he's only
in one scene and he's not suiting up as
a superhero and from what i've been told
i don't think it's this scene it's not
going to be doctor strange because well
we already know he's in the film that's
not really a secret and the thought of
it being another avenger i think that's
just a diversion i don't think that's
going to happen at all we already have
enough going on a whole entire sinister
six plus doctor strange and plus two
other spiderman and not to mention the
reddit user my time to shine hello who
has been accurate about previous leaks
in the past this person even went online
today and said he's talking about toby
and like i said this person has been 100
accurate to my knowledge about the leaks
that they've posted in the past so
there's no reason to doubt that this
person is accurate about it being toby
so literally everything points to this
fourth person being toby mcguire
spider-man plus who else is gonna make
tom holland and his brother's jaw drop
while watching this scene what's going
to be so iconic or more iconic than tom
holland spider-man talking with tobey
maguire spider-man like that's as iconic
as it gets and i'm just truly excited to
see this scene on screen i'm super
excited to see the other two spider-man
even though they're not confirmed
it's pretty much all but confirmed at
this point but let me know what you
think about this article about what tom
holland said in the comments down below
do you think it could be somebody else
besides toby or i'll throw in andrew as
well or do you think it's toby or andrew
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all of the latest
spider-man and mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram twitter
or tick tock and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you